자 그리고 개발할 때 필수 지식 꼭 알아야 되는 것들이 뭔가 왜 자꾸 자료 기조를 중요하다 하는가
그리고 저는 API가 뭐 개발이 있어서 가장 중요하다고 생각합니다. 가장 오픈 API는 뭔가
그리고 REST API는 뭔가 이런거 제가 Q.
태크 노트 위키 한번 들어볼까요
자 API 한번 쳐봤습니다 API 서로가 통신을 하기 위한 규약이나 약속이십합이다
그리고 내부 구현을 알 필요 없이 API 제공한 기능과 형식을 맞춰 요청을 보내면 원하는 결과를 얻을 수 있다
자 이렇게 좀 정의가 되어 있어요 조금 어려운데
자 여기 보면서 조금 한번 설명을 잠깐 드리면 자 결국은 이거요
프론트 핸드 지금 계속 강조 드렸죠. html css 같은 걸로 하면 만들고
javascript로 동적인 처리 해주고 이렇게 이벤트라고 했어요 버튼을 눌렸을 때 버튼 처리 해주고 이런 겁니다
리액트나 뷰나 앵글러로 하면 만들어요 자 이런 식으로 프론트 핸드가 있고
백엔드가 있다 노드로도 서버 띄운다라고 말씀드렸어요. java, sprint, pysun으로도 가능합니다. 예전에는 PHP로 했고요
마이예스 퀴엘 몽고 디비는 디비에요. 디빈데 이렇게 같이 있는 거죠. 백엔드에. 백엔드가 여기까지인데 결국은 데이터는 어딨냐면 백엔드에 있어요
데이터가 여기에 저장되어 있다는 거예요. 저장되어 있는 데이터를 가지고 오려면 그냥 데이터베이스로 접속을 해서 이렇게
뭐 갑자기 html에서 이렇게 슝 해가지고 슝 해서 이렇게 접속하는 게 아닙니다.
그게 아니고요 api라는 걸 두고 이 api가 서로 교환을 해주는 거예요 데이터를 결국 api는 뭐라는 거냐 데이터 교환을 하는 목적이에요
그 백엔드 서버는 뭐냐 api를 제공함으로써 그 데이터를 주고받는 역할을 한다라는 거죠
그랬을 때 노드로도 서버를 띄울 수 있고 pysun으로도 쓸 수 있고 java로도 띄울 수 있어 라고 말을 하는 거고요
그러면 백엔드 서버가 api를 제공하는 거고요. 이렇게 그러면 여기에 접속을 해서 이렇게 호출을 하는 거고요
제공한 그 백엔드 api 서버가 응답을 주는 겁니다. 응답을 줘서 데이터를 전달해주는 그 데이터는 어디 있냐 이 데이터베이스이다
그런 게 api입니다. api를 쓰는 것이 거의 개발에 뭐 많은 부분이에요. 왜냐하면 아까도 말씀드리지만 프론텐드에서는 화면 만들고요
이벤트 처리하고요. 3번 데이터를 교환하는데 api로 호출하고 응답받아서 데이터를 보여주는 그게 거의 프론텐드 개발의 전부고
백엔드는요. api를 제공하고요. 그리고 api를 요청을 받으면 어떤 로직이 있으면 로직 처리해주고 결국 이 데이터 웨이스에 가서
데이터를 가져와 가지고 응답해주는 게 거의 대부분의 일입니다. 그래서 이렇게 프론텐드 백엔드가 이런 식이다라는 큰 그림을 이해하시는 게 좋다
자, rest api. api는 api인데 rest 규격을 따른다. rest도 일정의 약속입니다. 규격이고
Representational. Representation이라는 것은 표현이라는 그런 용어이고 표현을 이렇게 하는 거죠. 예를 들면 http에
그 메소드들이 있어요. get, post, put, delete
이런 메소드들이 사실 어떤 걸 하려는지 굉장히 명확하게 알려줘요. 이게 좀 중요한데 뭐냐면 지금 프론텐드가 있고 백엔드가 있다고 말씀을 드리고
또 백엔드가 있지만 또 다른 서버에서 오픈 api를 제공한 경우도 있습니다. 그러면 이제 뭘 하고 싶냐면 이렇게 서로 간에 주고받는 일이 굉장히 많은데
매번 이 api는 뭐예요? 어떤 기능이에요? 이러고 싶지 않은 거예요. 왜냐하면 이런 식으로 오픈 api까지 제공을 하니까 누구든지 쓸 수 있게 제공을 하고 싶으니까
물론 여기에 규격이 다 제공이 되는 편이에요. 그런 식으로 어떤 정의서 명세서를 주긴 하는데
그 명세서를 일일이 다 전달할 필요는 없게 하고 싶은 거죠. 이왕이면 api를 딱 정의해놓으면 이러한 약속을 서로 지켜놓으면
개발이 쉬우니까 예를 들면 계시면 항상 읽기를 하자. post면 항상 입력을 하자. 입력이라는 건 데이터베이스에 입력이에요.
post면 수정을 하자. delete면 삭제를 하자. 이러면 api 이름만 알면 그 api를 처리할 수 있어요.
front-end 개발자도. 백엔드 개발자도 이 규약이 있으면 좋죠. 예전에 php 있을 당시에 어떤 일이냐면
이름에 붙었어요. php 이름에. 개쇼. 뭐 있어요. 이름에다가 php 이름에다 그 용도를 붙여. 그 목적을 역할을 막 불치는 거에요. delete-shop 이렇게 해가지고 그걸 자꾸 이름에다 했었어요.
그래야 아니까. 그래야 이후 후출할 때 이게 무엇이다라는 걸 알잖아요. 근데 이것만 봐도 솔직히 알긴 알죠. 뭐 나쁘지 않죠. 근데 이제 나뻤어요. 왜냐하면 그걸 그대로 명명구치를 쓰지 않는 경우도 많고
그걸 또 이렇게 붙였다가 뒤에다 붙였다가 뭐 할 수 있잖아. 이름이 얼마든 자기 마음대로 만드니까. 근데 이렇게 함으로써 여기에 이걸 떼는 거예요.
여기다 이름에도 붙이지 말고. 그건 shop이라고만 해. ui라고 하는데.
shop이라고만 하면 개수로 메소드로 후출하고 shop을 이렇게. shop을 후출하면은 읽기만 하. 그리고 포스트로 하면은 이 shop 데이터를 입력해.
그리고 푸스는 수정해. delete는 삭제해. 이런 식으로 규격화 했다라는 것의 형태가 last api다. 그리고 lastfool은 그 last api를 굉장히 잘 지킨 api를 lastfool이라고 합니다.
이 정도면 이거 안 보셔도 돼요. 사실 상세한 내용 안 보셔도 이 정도만 듣고 가셔도 됩니다.
그런 식으로 함수 클래스 객체 라이벌이 쭉 설명했는데 이게 되게 이제 많습니다. 되게 많아요.
비동기 동기가 또 개발이 있어서 정말 가장은 아니고 가장 중요한 거 1번 가장 다음으로 중요한 거 2번 동기 비동기.
동기는 쉽게 말하면 이게 함수를 후출했는데 함수가 응답될 때까지 기다렸다가 응답이 처리되고 나서 진행되는 거.
함수라는 것은 아시죠. 그니까 무슨 기능을 만들어 놓은 거예요. 기능. 예를 들면 가장 쉬운 함수는 뭐 인티저. 그냥 그 시연어로 예를 들게요.
에드 인티저 에이컵마 인티저 B.
리턴 A 플러스 B. 이런 게 함수잖아요. 여기에 뭐 집어넣고
결과 나오면 이런 게 함수잖아요. 함수까지는 아시죠. 이런 게 함수인데
지금 함수의 결론이 아니에요. 함수는 안 닫히고. 함수는 여기에 뭔가 더하기면 더하기.
노란색으로 칠해줘. 그것도 함수고. 무슨 기능을 하는 게 함수예요. 함수는 펑션이라고 합니다. 펑션. 펑션은 기능이라고 하고요.
기능을 처리하는 것이 함수다. 자 에드는 간단한 함수지만 이게 점점 복잡해지면 다 함수예요. 함수의 조합이 프로그래밍이에요.
결국은 함수의 조합이에요. 다 이가 함수들입니다. 클래스 안에도 함수도 있고요. 내부 함수도 있고.
객체는 클래스로 만든 거고요. 라이브러리 클래스가 모여져 있는 거고요. 이 모여진 것을 의미 있게 묶어서 SDK를 만들고요.
모줄은 라이브러들이 의미 있게 모인 것들. 인스턴스는 이런 것들이 실행되고 있는 것들.
컴포넌트는 더 화면 레벨. 프레이머그는 개발 도구. 이미 틀을 어느 정도 만들어주는 수준. 프레이머그라고 합니다.
사실 이거 스프링 부트도 프레이머그예요. 스프링 프레이머그예요. 가장 큰 범위죠. 왜냐하면 이 안에 SDK도 있고 컴포넌트도 있고
모줄도 있고 라이브러리도 엄청 많고 클래스도 많고 그래서 어느 정도 기능들을 개발하기 쉽게 제공을 합니다.
그 정도 레벨. 여기서부터 사실 신경 써서 쭉 범위를 좀 크게 넓힌 거예요. 함수가 가장 단인 생각을 하고 했습니다. 가장 작은 단인. 가장 작은 단인.
그러면 지금 함수 얘기를 왜 했냐. 동기 비동기예요. 이 계산이 끝나야 리턴이 된다. 아 이거 금방 되잖아요. 금방 오죠.
금방을 말하는 게 아니라 이게 만약에 10초 걸린다면.
아 에이브러스트 B가 10초가 아니라 그냥 무슨 일을 하는 데 있어서 10초가 걸린 일을 여기서 처리하는 함수라면 그것을 기다렸다가 진행하면 동기.
그걸 안 기다리고 그냥 진행되면 비동기. 끝. 자 통신에서 예를 들어 볼게요. 통신으로 얘기를 들으면 더 좋아요.
왜냐하면 이건 에이브러스트 B가 10초 걸린다는 건 억지스럽잖아요. 통신에 있어서. 통신을 쫙 썼어요. API를 썼어요.
API를 응답될 때까지 3초가 걸려요. 현실적으로 3초 걸리는 경우 있어요. 10초가 걸리는 경우도 있고. 3초가 걸리는 동안 계속 기다렸다가 다음 처리 했으면 동기.
3초 딱 API 써 놓고 몇 초가 걸릴지 몰라. 관심도 없어. 그냥 딴 일 해. 딴 일 해. 딴 일이라는 건 사실 별거 없어요. 그냥 자유롭게 컨트롤될 수 있게 놔주는 거예요. 기다리지 않는다는 거죠.
그 상황에서 이게 3초 뒤에 알람이 와. 우리 그 카페 가면 알람 그거 주잖아요. 알람이 와. 알람이 오면 다시 딱 찾아가서 처리하면 돼. 비동기.
예전에 카페를 생각하면 동기였었던 상황도 있었을 거예요. 왜냐하면 줄서서 기다리고 어디가 동기냐면 은행이 그랬어요. 은행. 예전에. 아 예 그때가 없나?
아 여러분은 그때 없었나요? 저는 줄서서 기다렸어요. 정말 1시간 기다린 적도 있었어요. 왜냐하면 앉아 있으면 다른 데 가서 앉아 있으면 자리 뺏기니까.
줄을 서서 월급날이면 정말 통장 들고 가서 얼마 들어 찍어보려고 은행에서 그 쭉 줄서서 기다렸어요. 그때 앉아 있는 것도 없어서 다 서서 기다렸어요.
앉아 있는다? 상상도 못할 일이었어요. 근데 어느 순간 은행에 갔다 앉아 있더라고. 정말 참신하고 획기적이었고 앉아도 되나 싶었어요.
감히? 아니 아니 감히는 아니지만. 아무튼 그런 상황이었는데 갑자기 은행 얘기를 하냐. 이게 적절하니까. 어느 순간 그 발급 봤잖아요.
알람. 알람 받고 그 번호표. 번호표 봤잖아요. 이러니까 내가 자유도가 핸드폰을 보고 있어도 되고 딴 짓을 해도 되고 화장실 갔다 와도 되고 탁 이렇게 하다가
띵동 울리면 가면 되잖아요. 카페도 마찬거죠. 이게 삶의 질 높였죠. 비동기로 가면서 뭐가 가능하냐.
앱이라는 것은 대부분 네톡통신을 해요. 다 API를 지금 주건이 바꾸고 있어요. 주건이 바꾸고 있어요. 근데 우리가 앱을 딴 거 누를 수 있죠.
그거 자체가 비동기가 되기 때문입니다. 동기라면 아무것도 못해요. 심지어 화면이 갱신도 안 돼.
아 이거 그 시분할 같은 걸 할 때 이제 점점 깊어지면 다음 다음에 컴퓨터 구조 나와요. 이게 이제 이게 설명이 자연스럽게 앞으로 계속 가는 거예요. 왜냐하면
왜 그러면 그게 갱신도 안 됩니까 이게 이제 시분할이라는 거예요. 컴퓨터 구조 운영체제에 있어서 그 원리에 의해서 이게 동작되기 때문에
만약에 얘가 동기로 잡고 있다면 아무것도 못하는 거예요. 그래서 멀티스레드 개념도 나오고 비동기 개념도 나오는 겁니다. 여기까지는 이제 모셔도 되고
어쨌든 동기와 비동기는 이러한 개념이다 정도까지는 AI로 하든 뭘 하든 좀 아시는 것이 필요하다 저는 그렇게 생각하고 API는 당연히 알아야 되고요.
이게 우리가 쓰는 대부분이 레스트 API를 추종하고 있다는 것도 아셨으면 좋겠고요.
그러한 레스트를 굉장히 잘 지킨 API들이 레스트 풀 API라고 생각하시면 되는데 레스트 풀이라는 표현을 다 쓰는 경우는 거의 없어요. 레스트 API라고 하죠.
그런 정도 그래서 그 데이터를 주고 받는 것이 xml제이스입니다. xml제이스는 프로그램이 아닙니다. 데이터 포맷이에요.
오늘은 좀 안쪽까지 좀 보여드리려고. 이게 xml 데이터 형태예요.
이게 요소를 가르치는 거고요. 이름이 보다 나이가 보다 어떤 도시다. 이게 실제 데이터예요. 이게
그런 거죠. 네임 이콜 전 도. 나이 30. 시티 뉴욕.
이런 형태가 xml라는 형태고요. xml는 언어가 아니에요.
뭐 그 언어라는 표현이지만 그렇죠. 마크업 랭기지라고 해서 hml도 언어죠. 언어가 아니냐 기냐를 떠나서 프로그래밍이 아니라는 거죠.
개발을 위한 데이터를 담을 수 있는 그런 틀인 거고.
제이스는 위에 내용을 그대로 한다면 이런 식의 중가로와 큰 다운표 그리고 점에서 퍼스를 담는데
이제 이름은 여기 담고 나이는 이렇고 뭐 뉴욕 이렇게 채워 넣는다. 이게 제이스입니다. 제이슨으로 주고 받는다고 보면 싶은데요.
지금의 대부분의 API는 대부분 제이슨이라고 보시면 돼요. 제이슨으로 거의 이제 다 제이슨으로 됐습니다.
잘 보시면 이게 좀 더 효율적이에요. 데이터를 담는 데. 왜냐하면 여기에 아무래도 네임, 네임 이렇게 꺽세를 하고 이렇게 이름을 다 적는 게 조금은 비효율적인 부분이 좀 있습니다.
이것만 봐서는 조금 비슷해 보이는데 그렇습니다. 제이슨을 좀 아시는 거는 필요하다.
폴링 이벤트 중요하죠. 폴링은 이렇게 아쉽네요. 폴링은 주기적으로 이렇게 체크하는 거.
계속 5초마다 한 번씩 뭔가 확인한다. 들어왔니 안 들어왔니 들어왔니 안 들어왔니 이벤트 방식 이렇게 이벤트 알려줘. 나한테 무슨 일 있으면 딱 일이 생겼을 때
주는 거. 그게 이벤트 방식. 중요한 차이가 있습니다. 이벤트 방식 버튼 눌린다 이벤트예요.
폴링으로 그렇게 하면 비효율적이죠. 계속 매번 1초마다 한 번씩 눌렸냐 눌렸냐 눌렸냐 할 수 없죠. 할 수 없을 뿐더러 비효율적이죠.
비효율적인 푼더러 할 수 없어요. 그러면 이거는 어떤 경우 냐. 약간 뭐 데이터가 들어왔나 안 들어왔나.
그것 또한 뭐 이벤트 방식이면 좋은데 한 프로그램 내에서는 얼마든지 이벤트로 다 할 수 있는데 이게 프로그램이 서로 달라요.
예를 들면 이쪽에서 뭐 데이터나 파일을 주기로 했어. 그래서 얘가 이 프로그램 볼 수는 없고 어떤 중간에 저장소를 지금 같이 바라보고 있어.
파일, 파일 저장이나 데이터. 그럼 얘는 여기를 주기적으로 볼 수밖에 없는 사항도 있어요. 그래서 폴링 방식도 있다라는 거고. 그런 차이가 있다라는 겁니다.
지난번에도 이렇게 좀 정리를 하고 나눴는데 조금씩 제가 더 안쪽 내용도 같이 좀 겸해서 말씀드리려다 보니까 아직 많이 남아 있어요. 5장, 6장, 7장, 8장, 9장, 10장까지 있습니다.
그래서 제가 더 영상을 좀 계속 올릴게요. 올리는데 한 줄 한 줄 얘기하기는 좀 한계가 있어서 이렇게 좀 한번 이해를 돕기 위한 내용이고 이미 좀 구매하신 분들도 계시고 또 이것만으로도 좀 도움이 되실 분들도 계시고 좀 구매하셔서 보실 분들을 위해서 제가 계속 영상으로 좀 올려드리려고 하고요.
결국 AI 시대에 좀 알아야 되는 직들은 특히 IT 직들은 있다. 여전히 있다. AI가 다 해주지만 곳곳에 알아야 되는 것들이 있다는 것을
시간이 오래 걸려서 6개월 공부해서 그럴 상황은 아니다. 그러니까 그런 정도 시간이 우리가 없다가 아니라 꼭 필요한 거 요즘으로 알아도 되는데 그게 이정도다라는 생각이 들고요.
또 좋은 내용으로 찾아뵙겠습니다. 감사합니다.